there's nothing more repulsive to a
woman than neediness in a man that is
the most repulsive trait is to be needy
well the problem is that phones and text
messaging and all of that stuff just
ignites this kind of neediness in people
and and like everyone is is like this to
a certain extent at this point not just
in relationships the very fact that the
other person has their phone on them at
all times you feel like you're entitled
to their attention all the time because
they have on them the means by which you
can get their attention right but you
aren't I mean you can't just barge in on
someone at all hours of the day
relentlessly whatever you feel like it
and expect that they'll drop everything
they're doing and respond to you it's
insane but it's an insanity that you're
in you're in good company because like
most of the country this is how they
operate if they send a text message they
expect an immediate response you know I
frequently get text messages and I don't
respond to them for days I treat text
messages like like their letters and I'm
living on the frontier in in 1835 and
the male comes by horseback every four
months